اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبيه الاتفاق على وضع
سقف اعلى لسعر النفط الروسي ومشتقاته عند
60 دولار للبرميل اعتبار من الاثنين
المقبل وكانت مجموعه الدول السبع الكبرى
واستراليا قد تبنت من قبل قرارا ممثلا
وجددت موسكو من جانبها رفضه واكدت انها
بصدد دراسه القرار تمهيدا للرد عليه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مساره ما هي المعطيات التي
حصلت قرار مجموعه السبع وحلفائها بتحديده
سقف لسعر النفط الروسي وما مدى امكانيه
تقبل الدول المعنيه مبررات الذهاب اليه ما
هي التاثيرات التي يمكن ان يتركها هذا
القرار على روسيا وحربها في اوكرانيا وما
الاوراق التي تستطيع استخدامها في مواجهته
وما هي الارتدادات المحتمله لهذا القرار
على سوق الطاقه العالميه في ضوء التحضيرات
الروسيه من تاثيره كسابقه في ربط اسعار
النفط باعتبارات السياسه
[موسيقى]
بعد ساعات من بياني لمجموعه الدول السبع
الكبرى اكد ان دول الاتحاد الاوروبي اتفقت
على تحديد المبلغ 60 دولارا سقفا لسعر
بربيل النفط المنقولي قبل البحر من روسيا
خرج الاتحاد لياكد الخبر الذي قال انه
سيمنع الزيادات الكبيره في اسعار النفط
وسيقلص قدرات الرئيس الروسي فلاديمر بوتين
في اطار الحرب التي يشنها على اوكرانيا
قرار الاتحاد الاوروبي كانت قد سبقته اليه
دول مجموعه السبع واستراليا مع اتفاق جميع
هذه الاطراف على ان القرار سيدخل حيز
التنفيذ يوم الاثنين المقبل
بعد طولي ترقب وفي ايطار رد الروسي على
قرار تحديد سقف لصعب النفط جدد لكريملين
رفضه وقال المتحدث باسمه ديمتر بيسكوف ان
بلاده استعدت لهذا القرار وانها كانت تعمل
على تحليله واضاف بسكوف ان موسكو لن تقبل
هذا السقف وانها ستدرسها على جناح السرعه
تمهيدا لاعلان ردها عليه
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع
الدراسات الاقتصاديه في معهد الطاقه
والتمويل في روسيا ومن واشنطن السيده ساره
رئيس شركه اس في بي للطاقه الدوليه
والخبيره في اسواق الطاقه العالميه مرحبا
بكما السيده ساره طبعا التوصل الى هذا
القرار شهد جدلا بين الدول التي اتفقت
عليه ما المعطيات التي ادت الى تحديد سقف
اعلى سعر النفط الروسي المنقول عبر البحر
اتفرج
انه لا يمكننا ان نحدده سقفاري
سلعه النحل ولا نتحكم بها ولا يمكن ان
ابيعها الان خلال فصل الشتاء حيث الطلب
كبير على النفط من كل دول العالم وبالنسبه
الى صادرات النفط الروسيه
ضخمه وبالتالي لا بديل عنها في السوق
وبناء عليه من الصعب بما كان الان
نستثنيه
اسعار لن تتمكن من الاستفاده من بيعها
النص ما يحصل الان هو ان هذا السقف الذي
اتفق عليه الاتحاد الاوروبي هو نفس الثمن
الذي تدفعه الصين والهند لروسيا
تدفعني
30$ تقريبا
سعر السوق اذا يمكن القول ان اتوقع من
خلال هذا السياسه تحاول ان تشتري ان نفطر
روسي بالسعر المخفض الذي تستورده الهند
والصين وبالتالي اوروبا سوف تشتريه بتخفيض
اكبر
امكانيه ان تتاقلم روسيا مع هذا القرار
كون هي اصلا تبيع
نفطها للصين والهند تقريبا بهذا السعر وفي
النهايه يؤمن لها تقريبا من 30 الى 40
دولار ربحا في البرميل الواحد في حال اا
كما تقول روسيا بان كلفه الانتاج 20
دولانا للبرميل الواحد
نعم شكرا لكم
اي من هذه الوسائل نعتقد ان وضع سقف
للاسعار هو شيء غير
مسبوق
مضر للعديد من الدول المصدره
للنفط في الاوبك وهذه الاسعار التي وضعوها
كحد اقصى وهي 60 دولار للبرميل هذا السقف
الواقع
اعلى
همم مما كانت في اليوروز وهي الماركه
الاساسيه التي تتاجر وتصدرها روسيا واعتقد
ان هذه الوسيله همم وضع سقف اعلى للاسعار
لن يؤثر
على
تصدير النفط الروسي الان بالنسبه لروسيا
من الاهم
الاثار السلبيه
من
شراء النفط الروسي في اوروبا
هذا القرار باعلى المجموعه الدول السبع
والاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا الاستراليا عن
تحديد سقف لسعر النفط الروسي المنقول بحرا
وقالت الوزير الامريكيه ان القرار سي
يساعد في تقييد مصدر دخل الرئيس بوتين
لتمويل حربه في اوكرانيا مع الحفاظ على
استقرار امدادات الطاقه عالميه وذكرت
الوزيره في بيانيا سقف للاسعار مصمم
للمساعده في حمايه المستهلكين والشركات من
اضطرابات الامدادات العالميه من ناحيتها
قل موسكو من تاثير قرار تحديد سقف لسعر
نفطها واكدت على لسان نائب رئيس الوزراء
الكسندر نوفاك انها ستعمل فقط بشروط السوق
وانها لن تبيع نفطها للدول التي ستضع سقفا
للاسعار وفي سياق ذاته قال رئيس لجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الدومه الروسي ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي عبر قراره تحديد سقف
لسعر النفط الروسي المنقول بحرا سيسبب
لنفسه ازمه في مجال الطاقه واعتبر ان
القرار يصب في مصلحه الولايات المتحده
التي ستزداد ثراءا بسبب القرار بحسب قوله
همم سيده ساره
ما التاثيرات التي او المحتمله التي ربما
اتخذت هذه الدول مجموعه السبع والاتحاد
الاوروبي هذا القرار على اساسها ما
التاثيرات المحتمله على الداخل الروسي
بسبب الحرفي اوكرانيا طبعا فان الولايات
المتحده ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي بحجله
اتخاذ عدد من التدابير ضد روسيا ولكن وكما
اسلفت نصعب جدا
عقوبات على النفط الروسي في السوق لانه لا
بديل عنه حتى توقعات الاوبك بزياده
الانتاج
اظهرت فعلا
معطيات السوق وكما قال تدعو الاعضاء في
الاوبك لا يمكنها ان تعودها عن تبعد
مليارات برميل
روسيا حتى لو ان اعضاء الاوبك انت شو عند
على حد او قدره لهم وبالتالي خرج
قاعده الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهذا هدول بسياسه من اجل التصدي لروسيا
ومن خلال تحديث سقف لسعر النفط ولكن اذا
نظرنا الى كلفه الانتاج الروسيه فهي
متدنيه وبالرغم من ذلك فروسيا سوف تجني
ارباح انطائنا في سنتين الاخيرتين اذا
فكرنا ماليا خلالها رائحه كورونيا كان
السعر متدنيا 60$ للبرميل الواحد ليس
متدنيا الى درجه سوف يضر بالاقتصاد الروسي
او يحطمه طالما ان اسعار النفط هي عند 40
دولارا فان الاقتصاد الروسي سوف لن يعاني
ازمه و سوف يستمر بالعمل بطريقه طبيعيه
بناءا عليه
اذا وافقت روسي على تصدير نفطها
قد نفكر ان 80 دولار هما ستطلبه ولكن حتى
60 دولار ليس ساره متدنيا
واذا صدرت روسيا نفطها سوف لن تتضرر
القرار لا يضر بروسيا بيل هذا القرار
يساعد المستهلكين اذا وافقت روسيا على
اعتماد هذا السقف المحدد سيساعد ذلك
المستهلكين في اوروبا بدون ان يضر بروسيا
فعليا
المتوقع عليها داخليا وعلى تمويل حربها
باهظه التكلفه في اوكرانيا
اه يضمه
هذه القرارات لن يكون لها اي تاثير حقيقي
على التصدير تصدير النفط كما قلت بالنسبه
لي روسيا من اهم هي حظر النفط الروسي من
قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي اما الدخل الذي
ياتينا من النفط والغاز اعتقد ان هذا
الدخل بسبب ال ااه بسبب القيود على الطاقه
الروسيه اعتقد ان هذا الدخل سوف يقل وهذا
سوف يؤدي الى تقليل
الميزانيات من النفط والغاز انا روسيا
لديها مستوى متدني جدا من الديون الوطنيه
وحتى بعد هبوط مستوى الدخل من قبل الغاز
والنفط اعتقد ان في روسيا هناك تخطيط
لتقليل
في ال مستويات الضرائب لدرجه الثانيه في
المئه واعتقد ان هذا قد يقلل مستوى
قدره روسيا على تمويل الحرب ولكن هذا لن
يكون تاثير كبير جدا سيترى مده بدايه
الحرب الاتحاد الاوروبي قلل اصلا مشترياته
للنفط ومشتقاته النفطيه من روسيا ولكن هذا
لم يؤثر على تصدير روسيا للنفط
وانطلاقا من الكلام الذي تفضلت به في في
معرض جوابك الاخير اذا ما جد هذا القرار
طالما ان روسيا هذا القرار لن يؤثر كثيرا
على روسيا
وطالما ان بامكانها ان تجد سوقا بديلا
للاسواق التي قد تقفل في وجهها ربما جراء
هذا القرار
وحفته
في ان
صادرات
الروسيه تصدر عبر الانابيب والكثير من هذه
القيود والعقوبات هي مفروضه على النفط
المنقول بحرا
وبالتالي
واثير في صادراتها عبر الانابيب الانابيب
الغاز والنفط الى اوروبا
انا
هذا السياسات لتحديد سقف للسعر ليست جدول
ان العالم بحاجه الى نفط الروسي وروسيا
تدرك ذلك نحن الان في عز الطلب من حيث
واذا قررت روسيا ان توقف الصادرات كما
هددت راينا انها فعلت الامر نفسه بنسبه
الى صادرات الغاز الى اوروبا
كذلك من الصعب جدا ان نراقبه هذه السياسه
لا يمكن مراقبه كل دوله كل مستورد لان
نفطر روسي لكي نرى كم من كميات الثور ده
او اشترى لا يمكن ان نطالبه بمستندات
ووثائق تثبيت ذلك لكن سهل تزويرها ايضا
اذا تنفيذ ذلك والاهم مراقبه ذلك امر يكاد
يكون مستحيل
يعتبر ذلك بمثابه
سمع ايجابيه او افضليه سياسيه لصالح لدول
الاوروبيه ولكن
من الجانب العملي من الصعب جدا ان اراقبه
في هذا هو لن يؤذي روسيا اصلا
ربما ستصطدم موسكو بمشكله عدم القدره على
شحن هذا النفط بحرا كون الشركات التي
ستنقل هذا النفط الروسي مرتبطه بشكل او
باخر بشركات الاتحاد الاوروبي او شركات
غربيه وبالتالي لن تنقل النفط الروسي
طالما كان سعره اكثر من 60 دولار امريكيا
ما الخيارات المتاحه امام روسيا في هذه
الحاله ما الاوراق التي يمكن ان تمسك بها
للتحايل ربما على هذا القرار
روسيا بالفعل بدات باتخاذ خطوات
لكي تقلل تاثير
القيود
وحظر النفط
الروسي او وضع اي تقفل الاسعار
النفط هو تحت السيطره الروسيه ويعمل على
الشركات الروسيه و خلال همم السنه سوف
الشركات الروسيه بتجديد هذه السفن حتى
تؤمن نقل النفط المساله الثانيه هي
التامين تامين السفن كل هذه السفن الشحن
ان يجب ان تكون مؤمنه الان 90 ب 95% من
هذه التامينات تؤمن من شركات بريطانيه
ولكن عند روسيا شركات تامين خاصه بها
منتميه للبنك المركزي الروسي وعندها سوف
يقدم البنك المحلي لخدمه لهذا اللي سفن
الشحن
وروسيا سوف تقدم تامين همم وضمان ودعم
حكومي لهذه الشركات طيب بالضبط اذا قام
الزبائن مثل الصين والهند باتخاذ قرارات
واذا دعموا هذا التامين وقبلوا به عند
نقل وشحن عن نفسه سوف يستمر دون اي عوائق
كان هناك موقف للسفاره الروسيه في
الولايات المتحده حيث حذرت من زياده واسعه
النطاق في عدم اليقين وبارتفاع تكاليف
المواد الخام بسبب تحديد سقف النفط الروسي
كما اشارت السفاره الى جميع الدول اضحك
غير محصنه ضد فرد سقف على صادراتها لاسباب
سياسيه بحسب تعبيرها السيده ساره ما الا
بدات المحتبله على سوق النفطه العالميه
يعني هل يمكن ان ان تتخذ هذه الدول
الولايات المتحده الدول السبع الاتحاد
الاوروبي واستراليا هذا القرار دون ان
تكون متاكده بان لن يكون له ارتدادات
واسعه على نطاق او على اسعار الطاقه
العالميه
واي دونه
ام لا ولكن الكثير من الخبراء ومنهم ان
انا
حذروا انه في حال اعلنت روسي انها لن تصدر
النفط الى دول التي تحدد سقفا لسعر
النفطها كما فعلت مع الغاز
سوف يكون هناك نفس كبير وسوف كثيره الا
اذا فكرت هذه الدول ان روسيا سوف تصدر
معظم وقتها للصين والهند ودول اسيويه
بينما الدول الافريقك ودول الخليج العربي
التي
تصدر الى روسي توجه نفطها الى اوروبا ولكن
طبعا هذا سيؤثر تاثيرا كبيرا على الاسعار
اذا ارتفعت الاسعار بسبب القرار الروسي
اذن هذا السقف ايضا سوف يرتفع مره اخرى
روسيا لن تخسر كثير للاسف
خالص
خالصه المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي الخروج
بخطط واسياسات من اجل الحج من المداخيل
الروسيه لان البحاجه الى نفط الروسيه وعلى
المدى القادسيه ما منحل سريع او سحريا
لهذه المشكله ولهذا من الصعب جدا على
السياسيين وصانع القرار ان يحددوا سقفا
الروسي واذا نظرنا الى ما يحصله هناك حظر
على نفط الايراني لا احد يمكنه شراء النفط
الايراني ولكن هذا لا ينطبق على روسيا اذا
استيراد انه روسي ليس غير مشروع ولا يمكن
انه نحدد من يشتريه باي سعر
هذه السابقه بان يتم تحديد سقف همم سلعه
تصدرها دوله الى الى دوله اخرى كيف ترى
موسكو ربط اسعار النفط
باعتبارات السياسه في هذه المرحله
تنظر الى هذا على ان تحديد مستوى الاسعار
هذا يتضارب مع
مبادئ السوق والتجاره التي تتعامل بها
الدول لذلك تحديد سقف للاسعار يعني ان على
سبيل المثال دول الغرب تحاول ان تحدد
الاسعار التي على روسيا كدوله مستقله ولها
سياده همم الاسعار التي على روسيا ان تت-
تتاجر بها مع الهند لذلك هذه الادوات
والسياسات ممكن ان يكون لها اثار بعيده
المدال لانه بعد فتره ممكن ان تقوم دول
اخرى همم التي تصدر النفط ايضا ربما من
الشرق
الاوسط ممكن ان يصبحوا اهدافا لمثل هذه
السياسات والاساليب لذلك همم ان القرار
الذي تم من اوبك ان يقلل انتاج النفط هذا
يعني ان دول الاوبك يفهمونا يتفهمون جيدا
هذه الخطورات ويقفون بجانب روسيا ومستعدين
ان يقوم بخطوره
في هذه النقطه سيده ساره سريعا لو سمحتي ب
30 ثانيه همم اريد ان اسمع رايك في هذه
النقطه تسييس همم تصدير النفط وماذا عن
مصير اوبك بلس التي تحدد عاده اسعار
الطاقه لو سمحت
بدي
بدايه الحرب على اوكرانيا
روسيا تصدر سبعه مليون
عاجزه عن زياده الانتاج بما يعوض عن
النقص الذي
يؤدي اليه
السوق
انها تنظر الى عناصر السوق وليس بطريقه
سياسيه ولا يمكن لاطراف ان تفرض على اوبتك
اتخاذ قرارات سياسيه لا تكون قائمه الى
متطلبات السوق
شكرا لكما السيده ساره فاكوري في واشنطن
والدكتور مارسل سالي خوف في موسكو
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا المتابعه الى اللقاء
بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]